[موسيقى]
بعد الفوز على تنزانيا والتعادل امام
جمهوريه الكونجو الديمقراطيه ثم التفوق
على زامبيا وبلوغ دوري ال 16 من المسابقه
الافريقيه هاهو المنتخب المغربي يقف امام
تحد جديد يتمثل في مواجهه جنوب افريقيا
وتجاوزها للتاهل الى الدوري ربع النهائي
المنتخب المغربي يعاني من عده اصابات في
صفوفه فبالاضافة
الاخيره امام زامبيا فقد تاكد غياب سفيان
بوفال بداعي الاصابه
ايضا المواجهه الاخيره بين المنتخبين كانت
ضمن تصفيات البطوله الافريقيه وانتهت
لمصلحه جنوب افريقيا بهدفين
لهدف بالنسبه لبوف فهو لن يشارك في
المباراه وقد انتهت كاس الامم الافريقيه
بالنسبه اليه خسرنا لاعبا مهما وقد حدث
ذلك خلال التدريبات تماما كما يمكن ان
يحدث في المباراه لكن المدرب البلجيكي
هيوجو بروس اقر بصعوبه المهمه في مواجهه
الليله بسبب ظروف البطوله
الحاليه انه امر ممكن لقد فزنا العام
الماضي وربما يمكننا فعل ذلك هذه المره
ايضا ليس لان لديك افضل اللاعبين وربما
تكون المنتخب الافضل لكنكم جميعا رايتم
المفاجات في هذه البطوله واعتقد انها
ستكون مباراه صعبه لكلا
المنتخبين ويشارك منتخب جنوب افريقيا في
البطوله الافريقيه للمره الحاديه عش في
تاريخه وسبق له التتويج باللقب في نسخه 96
من القرن الماضي على حساب منتخب
[موسيقى]
تونس